and when i'm in l.a i'll do it because i
was homeless here once and i'll hand out
hundred dollar bills i'll just go back
to this for you
and i just keep on walking and one lady
they gave a stack to it was a ten
thousand dollar stack
she was just the kind of sweetest lady
and i talked to her a little bit
she told me a little about her life and
i said can i give you a couple dogs oh
no no
i found out a way to make it okay
because i don't like to ask for anything
they said okay so i just held her hand
and i said can i put a note in your
pocket sure so i just put
a note in the pocket i realized this
built ten thousand output in her pocket
there was folded
with a rubber band i said you are so
blessed
once you wait a few minutes before
reading my note say a little prayer then
read the note okay
and i disappeared i believe that each
and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we
really want and i want to help give you
the tools
to make that happen i'm danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense welcome to the
pretty intense podcast on the show today
is john paul dejoria
he is of course one of the co-founders
of paul mitchell
which i used as a kid growing up all the
time those amazing
black and white bottles we had the giant
pump ones
and i always knew that i was using a
really great product and um
you know john paul commented on how
lovely my hair is now so i'm sure that
has to do with how well i've been taking
care of it since a young age so
i guess kind of thanks mom and dad for
buying really good hair products
um man i i'm just going to say that
we took a lot of unexpected turns in
this conversation
um i absolutely
loved it but did not expect certain
things to come out like
i don't know stuff about aliens and
integrotron out in joshua tree
we went all over the place but really a
fundamental about
john that is uh clear is his
immense positivity and his love of
giving back
and um and uh you know not just just
giving his money away as he would say
but to
to help build things for people to
create a
stronger foundation and to grow and
expand and he's some he's got some great
stories about
um what has happened as a result of
those uh those
those ways that he's given back um and
how people have gained their strength
and become more independent so
um fantastic guy uh just
you know someone that you just want to
be more like so please enjoy this
episode
i think i told you that uh as a kid i
used paul mitchell all the time we had
the
gigantic pump bottles oh yeah the
black and white classic black and white
bottles and we used him as a kid all the
time growing up i thought it was like
smelled so great and then there was the
awa and you can even say it that's very
lovely you can't say alba you get sad i
i was like wow this is the fanciest
stuff
it's so cool your hair looks great so it
worked out well
well i've been taking care of it from a
very young age see that yeah
but you've had such an impressive run of
amazing companies
and you know just when you think paul
mitchell is
you know humongous there are others but
what made me most curious is i couldn't
really figure out
what it was that at a young age made you
want to get into
to hair to hair care good story
good story i was uh 26 years old went
through a variety of jobs i hadn't been
to college
at least not to attend college uh 26
years old worked for time inc
and i walked up to my manager one day on
the west coast here and
i kind of ran a big boiler room for time
live fortune sports illustrated said
well how do i get to become a vice
president
he says you have no college whatsoever
and you're only 26 years old
come back and ask me when you're 35. i
thought i don't want to run this boiler
room with people on the phone all the
time for all these years so
a friend of mine john capra was an
employment counselor
so i went to him and he sent me to a
variety of jobs and one day and i didn't
like any of them
but i worked i did a good job i just
didn't like him one day he said jp
there's this opening you might just like
doesn't pay a lot of money but you go
anywhere you want is an unlimited field
it's a professional beauty industry and
one company that
works mainly with hairdressers i go
really so i interviewed for the job
obviously i got the position and that's
what
and he was right because in a year and a
half i went from being hired and knowing
nothing about hair
to their national manager of two
divisions but
i studied i studied hard i learned the
industry really quick and a lot of
people in management didn't do that
so it was the freedom or the the role
that you were looking for more than
anything
what was it that what was it that you
wanted that you
the the element that you wanted that you
didn't have element that i wanted
at that time was to be happy at what i
was doing
not go to work for a paycheck and that
was a big switch i wasn't happy where i
was at
i sure wouldn't be happy there for
another nine years so i was looking for
something that would make me happy in
the beauty industry i thought would make
me happy as i got into it
i found hairdressers are real fun they
were like yeah why did you
why did you think it would make you
happy i just i didn't know i was looking
i didn't know
so when i i had a series of jobs before
that and none of were
just really ideal for me you know they
weren't i wasn't really happy
i really wanted to be here forever and
ever and ever or for a long time yeah
i think there's such value in that in
doing something that you actually enjoy
because you tend to do it better
so when you're not happy it doesn't mean
you can't do a good job but
you know there's some magic in really
enjoying where you're at
i try and tell students why do i lecture
in colleges now and i haven't attended a
new lecture at them and
for some of our agencies have already
gone to college either so good cool
how many commencement speeches have you
been asked to do a few yeah exactly
i'm like i'm not sure what i'd like to
tell them all is this because people say
well how do you know what you want in
life how do you find your dream
what you want and i tell them all
exactly the same thing
i don't think any of us or maybe a few
exceptional ones
know exactly what you want to do because
it changes
but you know what you don't want to do
the minute you find what you don't want
to do and you know for sure you want to
do it
get out of there get out there's a lot
of people that are scared and i think a
lot of people get stuck
you know the system of you know you said
you didn't go to college the system of
going to college and
you know being in the hole and having to
just take any job
possible to make ends meet you don't
have the ability
to risk anything because you're you're
you know you're tied down by bills and
debts and so
you know i think i time and time again i
say how
valuable it is to just get out into the
world and do things as opposed to
worrying so much about certificates
it is so true america still has an
opportunity
in 2000 i'm sorry 1980
inflation in twelve and the united
percent
unemployment ten and a half percent if
you could get a loan
if you could get a loan in 1980 and 81
your lowest
interest rate is 17
that's the primary okay and you have to
wait in line for gasoline in our
and our houses we're still in iran worst
time to ever start any business anywhere
when we started paul mitchell we went
for half a million dollars we had a
backer
never gave us a dime the day i left
everything i did the backer didn't nope
never gave us one dime the day we were
ready the money was supposed to come
into bank of america in universal city
my relationship wasn't going good i left
her the house
the best car i took the used car down
the hill a couple hundred dollars in my
pocket there's half a million sitting
there my partner flew it from hawaii
paul that's where he and his girlfriend
lived
because he wanted some bucks he was on
his last dollars too and he's a little
older than i was
it never came in the money never came
and the guy said
sorry last minute change of mind gave us
all the reasons as to why
so there we were zero we started paul
mitchell
with 350 each i lived in the back of my
car
and there's a good little film to watch
it's called good
fortune how in life you could start with
little to nothing you could be homeless
you could be fired from multi-jobs which
i was by the way
and you can still succeed if you believe
in yourself
help people along the way no matter how
bad the circumstances are
america still works it's uh i know
youtube has that amazon has it it's
called good fortune
yeah it won the sedona film festival the
year before last in fact
they required it being held over if they
wouldn't mind so the whole city could
watch until everyone had a chance to
watch it
check it out good fortune the movie it's
an hour and 29 minutes long and it's all
about
how america still works it's a patron
story the paul mitchell story
and a lot of helping not what i have but
what i've done some of the things i've
done with what i have
i'd love to watch it i i'm really a
consumer of
information as opposed to junk i'm not
the kind of person that
you know sits and watches gossip to you
know reads gossip magazines and watches
uh you know desperate housewives so i'd
love to watch that
um but what made you believe it i mean
350 versus half a million dollars is a
big difference
boy do you ask good questions okay
that's the grain for the audience
why no money it didn't come in we had
been working on through friends of mine
in the industry
a couple of great formulas for hair and
i just knew
that if i could get in front of enough
people and tell them
what the bet my feature is in this
product that other products don't have
and how it's going to benefit them if i
could only do that people will buy it
but i can't talk to millions of people
we had no money no advertising
yeah so i knew it was that good we i was
in the salon business i mean
for working for manufacturers my partner
was a great stylist he thought he was an
educator for
many many people paul was a super
stylist
and he was a great educator known as one
of the best educators to attend to
so what happened was we went
door-to-door yeah how we started all
those bob mitchell schools yeah does
that work
we did that later on we did that we
started those about 15 years ago
but i went here in southern california
up ventura
door boulevard door beauty salon a
beauty salon trying to sell my products
because we had nothing but i knew if a
hairdresser who knows about hair
said this is unbelievable i'm only going
to use them or recommended the customer
and our two unique things we had were
one shampoo not two
if you only have one shampoo and it does
the job in most cases
you don't waste that extra time the
extra shampoo with the back basin
our conditioner you left in your hair
so you didn't have to wait 10 minutes
more hot water and
because of the condition in your hair it
also moisturizes your skin
you cut it better when you blow dry it's
a protector
and it neutralizes all the chemicals in
your hands when you put it on
so this was uniqueness so once the
hairdressers knew it was very slow i
mean
our first year in business with
everything we had going for us which was
zero right but we worked so hard we did
almost four hundred thousand dollars
gross in business that was gross of
course we didn't make any money it was a
couple years before we made a little bit
it was still very important oh yeah it
was day to day but we knew what we had
was so good
yeah if we could just tell enough people
about it and we waited it out
don't they say it's you know to really
know if a company is going to work or
not give it five
i mean so that's that's that's amazing i
mean distribution is always a question
right like
being able to get it into people's hands
and get it so what was the
so was what was the magic formula does
everyone use it now or is it still um
proprietary it's uh well the people used
all over the world we're in 103
countries throughout the world oh your
special formula the
the reason why it's so unique and the
little special thing yeah
there's great things out there right now
like it's like it's like the coca-cola
recipe right
i think theirs is a little more more
sophisticated but you know
a question i know you're going to ask me
and i'll answer it for you before you
even ask me is you have no
you have money you have no money you're
going a door you're trying to sell
something
how the heck do you get a distributor to
sell a product that is
unknown with people that are unknown
that have no money to do anything
i got my first 12 salons it took me a
week to do right
had them write out a check anywhere from
27 dollars to maybe 130
but leave it blank and they gave me
checks i'd leave the check blank oh yeah
leave the check blank okay you got them
to give you these
fill it out for the amount got it but
not who it's too oh
and then i would deliver it was products
from my car i got 30-day credit that's
how i got products in my car
30-day credit from the vendors okay and
so they give me a check right took me a
week to do it
so i went to paris a speedy supply the
biggest in southern california out of
l.a
and went up to jim henrietta who was the
president of the time and said hi
paul mitchell here come we have three
products the shampoo one shampoo two the
conditioner
greatest thing since bees knees you know
etc etc long story short
how'd you like to be my distributor he
laughs at it's a great presentation but
why
i have all these big lines celine curtis
maudine the redkins i have everybody
why do i want to build you have no
advertising money no
nothing and i said and here's why and i
pulled out of my pocket 12 checks put it
right in front of them
and i said that your first 12 customers
fill your name in and if you'll only buy
two thousand dollars from us we were
really hard up just two hundred thousand
dollars from i mean two thousand dollars
two thousand two thousand you could have
an exclusive on all of los angeles
county and orange county
stay in business you were wheeling and
dealing well we did we were we were just
desperate is that you it was me was that
you you were the wheel and dealer and
then
well my partner was too but we were
desperate you know we had no money we
had
bills you have to give away more than
you wanted at some point in time or were
you able to maintain
only once a car i had to give a car away
once uh but the end result was
he became a distributor and uh but
another thing too
the person you gave the car to no no he
wasn't that's another distributor about
a second but anyway he's this first guy
right uh and he told the story on our
25th anniversary which was 15 years ago
paul mitchell we
invited him over he said so jp leaves my
office but he asked me one thing before
he leaves
could you please pay me when the goods
are delivered and i said to jp
we're parasailing media supply we don't
pay our bills for 45 days
no and i said i'll be here every single
day and sell it till it's scott it's
only 2 000
you know begging him just he goes okay
the way he tells the story is so jp
leaves the office
five minutes later i get a phone call
the warehouse man
there's some guy here loading stuff on
our dock he wants to check for two
thousand dollars
he laughed his head off and of course he
did it and we sold his product out
within a week and a half so
that's how he started it was distributor
to this still friends of him
is he still around i haven't seen him in
about the last 10 years but i'm sure
he's pretty grateful
and he's glad to have taken the chance
sometimes you got to go with your gut
you know
he probably you were convincing you were
you say desperate but i would say
convincing
and he was going with his intuition and
saying like
you know what let's give these let's
give this guy a shot he seems he seems
motivated well
in order to be shall we stay successful
in anything success isn't just money
it's how you how good do you do what you
do i mean that's success
but some of the real keys to it would be
one
be prepared for a lot of rejection in my
early 20s i sold collier's encyclopedia
door-to-door
no appointments knocking you know
knowing you always go oh i hadn't
decided we had encyclopedia britannica
or whatever it was called
great well britannica got leads like
collier sweden was door-to-door
but you learn rejection and i believe
what they said because that was young
they said you're gonna have 100 doors
slammed in your face but on door number
101 you have to be just as enthusiastic
as the first door
and that's the only way to succeed at
this i believed him
so slamming the face or no sorry not
interested and i kept on doing it
and i did the same thing with paul
mitchell all these salons have said no
no no why do i
deal with that though how did you deal
with that much rejection
young well i wanted a job i got the
united states navy
and i heard all these glory stories
about all the commissions you can make
and
the regional manager was bj wright he
was 27 years old
and made 150 000 that year so he said
150 000 back in 1964 or 65 is a lot of
money it's like wow
you could do it too but you got to stick
by they were right
and you're going to have so much
rejection up about three days
is the average life of an encyclopedia
salesman selling door-to-door
but i believe him just stick it out
you're gonna get it you know when i got
my first order a week later it was yay
so it didn't really affect you you just
go and you went into it with a
perspective
that you were going to get rejected a
lot of rejection so then when you got
rejected you're like well there it is
exactly and if people know that whether
it's in your own personal life or your
mate rejects you your mother your friend
your uncle your school
and it would reject you no matter what
you do if you know what's going to
happen in your life happens to all of us
you're prepared for us yeah and the
effect isn't that much the second part
is
make sure your service or your product
is the best it can be
don't go into the selling business i'm
going to repeat that a second time do
not go into the selling business
go into the reorder business where your
product is so
good that you know when someone buys it
yeah they're going to want to either use
it again or recommend it to somebody
else if it's a one-time service
that's the key to longevity any business
and developing a product
you can have whistles and bells but if
it breaks the next day or doesn't work
sensationally
you don't have longevity yeah that's
absolutely true i mean so many people
think about
how do we get this into someone's hands
like right off the bat
how do we sell this and if you shift
your mindset to the reorder how do we
get them to reorder this
then it orients you to the quality
which is going to give you the
sustainability that's correct where
did someone teach you that or was this
just something that you enhanced
it's something that i realized was
happening and it was working extremely
well you know what also how did you
realize it was happening i got results
it got more sales
because the product was good the connect
was so good i got more sales out of it
was it more expensive than others
a little bit it was very cool just a
little bit more so let's say the average
shampoo at that time was maybe
three dollars and 50 cents ours was 3.95
but it was a little bit better and it
gave us that longevity
to see the sales come in the reorders
and it's our personal life's the same
way
in other words when you present to
another human being you know you could
present you'd be a great actor great
actress present something
but the longevity has to do with what is
the quality
that you're presenting that somebody is
saying that's your longevity
is it long lasting or is it i hope
everyone pauses on that and writes that
down
i mean that's true what do you bring to
the table what do you are you showing up
every day
bringing your best because that's your
longevity is that your
your your reorder right even in a
relationship you're a reorder every day
that is every day i like you i love you
that's right
that's right that's great and people if
you don't think that way it doesn't
happen
you know you take things for granted we
we're humans you know we're humans we've
been for 200
000 years and however we were created we
were we're here as we all we all do
human stuff
now where we created what do you think
well that's the whole other one i'll
gladly go over that sometime but you
better have
be ready for this look at the
reincarnation later
um so okay so paul mitchell's
a hit everywhere i used it
loved it smelled amazing obviously high
quality hair
um as a result patron so patron comes
along
like you're just like a hit list so
so tell the story about how patrons
started sure
and by the way in between paul mitchell
patron there were a few other couple
little things i started
that didn't go so well so not everything
i touched turns to gold it's nice to say
oh important i started
telecommunications
when i didn't know about it today you
know about it but uh and other unusual
things i thought would be great and they
just weren't
so it's about uh beginning late at 88
early 89.
i'm sitting i helped this young man out
named martin who went bankrupt in
hospitality
and i put him in the architectural
business i was the bank
he go to mexico buy pavers furniture
come back
sell it to restaurants and architects
for the model homes
so i was starting to build a home here
in malibu as a summer home for my family
and i said mark when you go down see if
they have some really old pavers for us
and by the way why don't you see what
they drink down there
because the tequila we drink here you
almost hold your breath with he goes
he comes back with these two really long
bottles
and it was the smoothest i've ever had
and i said wow martin that's really
smooth he says but
i met this guy francisco alcares he says
he can make it smoother
and then he showed me this bottle that
was made out of recycled glass i said
if we can make enough bottles let's say
a thousand cases 12 000 bottles
out of this recycled glass right with a
tequila
smoother than what i'm drinking right
now why don't we try going in business
i figured worse scenario because it was
very expensive if nobody buys it
for the next 10 years everyone you have
a baby here
is it yeah it's a character oh my gosh
in currency for 10 years
so what we took off uh nobody would take
us on nobody would take us
they said it's the best tequila we've
ever had but
for 37 a bottle to tequila
selling for four and five it's not gonna
happen no one's gonna buy it
so we finally convinced in los angeles
is where we started it
we convinced somebody there that was in
the wine business only to carry our
product
after a year and a half they only sold 2
000 cases so we dropped them went to jim
beam
big company you want to be our master
distributor you could sell to your
distributors oh great we'll take it
after a couple years with them they were
doing about 12 13 000 cases a year and
we said we should be doing a lot more
they said guys
let me tell you the truth we're jim beam
we know
your tequila is the best there is
there's none better but for by that time
it's 38 dollars a bottle right
and the most you can never do guys is
maybe 20 000 cases a year
that's it that's it guys no more okay we
took it back from them gave it to
seagram's
secrets built it up to 70 000 cases a
year at 38 of bottles
exactly and we knew that we could do a
better job ourselves we went to court we
bought them out of their contract we
took it over ourselves
and to give you tonight the growth of
patron uh when
i sold patron last year to bacardi we
were doing way over
three million cases a year and when you
put our whole brand together
over 40 million bottles a year way over
40 almost 50.
uh so anywhere so what they say was
wrong so sometimes
people that are experts tell you
something but if you believe in your
heart
with your heart not your head but your
heart that no that's not right i don't
care what an expert you are
we gonna get better we deserve better
you go for it yeah i want to talk about
that i want to talk about believing
because it's like
that's a that's a total [ __ ] it's a
common thread in success
but here it is again and you're hitting
on it so you know
what does it take to get to a place
where you really believe in something
like what is what what what do you need
to do or feel or experience or try or
vet out
what's the what's what's what's been
your formula
i have not had a formula and no one's
asked me that question before but i can
instantly answer it
and it's this be just be in your life
example i get up in the morning
and i learned this years ago and i
you go to the bathroom as you normally
do i have to go in the middle of the
night so
let's say then in the morning right yeah
i'm like i think i woke up at three it's
only
6 30. you just sit there and you clear
your mind that's not easy our minds go
fast so
i look at the wall i look at the ceiling
okay it's the ceiling
that's the lamp that's the bottom of the
bed oh there there's my dog susie out
say all right ready to jump in the
colorado river and
i just i focus right then i go right
back and maybe i'll look at a wall and
i'll just
clear my head anything enters my head
i'll look at the doorway i look at
anything to go into present time
it only takes a couple of just b
sometimes i close my eyes sometimes
they're open
i just be and then almost every single
day what comes out of me
either quietly or verbally loudly is
creator of souls thank you for this
incredible life you have given me
and help me see the truth and how i
could spread goodness with this blessing
you have given me
and then my mind is usually pretty clear
and then i go about my day
i don't think about things what i'm
gonna do during the day nothing until
that happens and i'm probably good for
that ninety-five percent of the time
you know it's just like what age did you
start doing that
whatever it is it just clears it you've
done that how long oh god i'd say for
i could even tell you at least a decade
maybe longer wow
just clears your head instead of
meditating there forever it's like
exercising
there are many exercises you could do
some it's an hour's worth of exercising
two hours three hours and all of a
sudden comes along an exercise
that takes 10 seconds but exercises
everything in your body that was a
shortcut but to accomplish the same
thing
so not that what i'm telling you and
your audience
surpasses meditating for hours i'm sure
that's probably great
i just didn't choose to do that and try
and find a shorter time
to do something would normally take a
longer time to achieve something good
well i think it is a form of it i don't
think there's an official way
i mean mindfulness i think you're
practicing mindfulness
presence i mean this is stuff that
cartoli would say to do
this is there's so many philosophers
would say to do that
leave yourself open i'm trying to say is
when you have that things come to you
so that was the last part of the answer
to your question is
if you could have yourself open to what
may come your way what to do what not
what to do leave yourself open
leave it open don't think with your head
your heart leave it open it comes to you
it's amazing it's just an amazing thing
it comes the answer comes to you
it's like kind of opening up to the
universe i am a firm believer
that the frequency of our planet and our
people is growing
i mean it is growing expanding right now
more people are getting smarter and
nicer
regardless no disrespect to the news but
all the [ __ ] they put on the news is
bad stuff usually it's not good stuff
amen i don't know but but but the world
is better than that now if you know
there are more people today per capita
per capita
doing good things for others than ever
in our history per capita in all
countries i go to it's just the most
amazing thing
i was just talking about this the other
day but um
someone was talking about how you know
there's there's this perceived amount of
negativity in the world and oh man
look how bad it is out there in
the nature of the nature of nature
is the balance and the duality of the of
the light in the dark
of the balance of good and evil or
positive and negative and so for
as bad as some things are there's the
good
too and so the good is bigger and the
goodest
i agree i think that i think it's almost
propaganda to
try and make people think that the world
is chaotic and
scary to create fear in people because
people keep people stay smaller when
they're scared
and it's another reason to why a lot of
things that have been found aren't
exposed to the public
like we did not start with our ancient
egypt just a few thousand years ago
and a big flood did happen about 10 000
bc
approximately nine ten thousand years
ago
and before that there were some very
advanced civilizations here
do you ever watch graham hancock or
listen to him
he was talking about an ancient
civilization and a catastrophic
sort of um event that happened
and maybe 12 years thousand years yeah
exactly yes that's correct
and it's interesting some of the things
that are being popped up right now they
just recently learned about for example
what you would call a flying saucer but
from
an ancient old dig that doesn't discount
any of the ones that are there today
okay so there's been and they're finding
cities now
way down turkey's digging up one right
now that's amazing
dates back at least 10 000 years but
other cities are under the water that
150 feet 175 feet
uh off the coast of uh cube off the
coast of india off the coast of japan
we actually see steps out of granite you
know out of
the park in the ocean that are easier to
see where the
blocks and the pathways and the and the
structures and water are
way too uniform to be um to be natural
so in genes
and some of our genes is still the
remembrance because some survive but
very few survivors somehow your james is
like a reaction
like you know after you feel heat you
move away there's some kind of reaction
so
when somebody is human beings all of a
sudden hear something negative and again
and again and again
and from the television set pretty soon
they're starting to believe it oh wow
that's what's going on things are really
bad
not realizing that the motivations get
your attentions we can sell ads on their
politicians same way
scare the life out of people oh this is
bad no there's no crisis going on yes
there is no there's not he's a bad guy
we hate him
i mean guys come on there's only so much
entertaining you can do
we the people of the united states of
america when you
travel when you meet people from whether
you're in a
bad area or of the of in america or
whether you go to a country that is
possibly scary
or they make you think it is all you
find is good people
i mean no no doubt there's some bad
apples out there
but i would say nearly
vast majority are good right like people
want
all the same stuff which is to love be
happy
joyful peaceful um they want all the
opportunity for safety right
to an interesting story in austin texas
we have a place called
mobile loaves and fish is the community
we built homes
little homes for the homeless we built
250 of them
if you're a homeless person and you're
without a shelter for at least a year
your priority we're gonna bring you in
you're under a bridge come here we're
gonna bring you in
we have three rules no drinking no drugs
and no fighting
that little house is yours forever as
long as you obey those right now
you're going to pay 90 a month for it
but i don't have any money
some people do some don't right no
problem we put you to work
we have elemental husbandry we have
gardens we have metal shop wood shop
everything all of a sudden they're part
of the community now here's people
that were homeless with no hope become
part of a community
are giving back and here's the greatest
story of them all
three months ago alan who's the main guy
putting this together alan graham came
he said jp
i'm gonna bring a tear to your eye i
said great it was actually thanksgiving
last year when i was serving food for
them and
at easter time anyway she said our
number one guy our first person to move
into one of the houses that i built
there for him
this blue beautiful little teeny house
right he says he's leaving us
i got to tell you the story he came up
and said alan i'm leaving
okay one i came here as a drunk i
immediately stopped drinking
my life got together i have a job i have
a car i have a girlfriend
and i'm gonna get an apartment and allan
says but you're my poster boy you can't
leave me you're the success story
and he looked him right in the eye and
he said and
that's why i'm leaving i can never thank
you for saving my life
the only way i can do it is to pass it
forward this is the best gift i could
ever give you
oh tears came out of my eyes that's an
idea if you give someone an
opportunity in life to be able to do
something properly with dignity and
include them and everything they're
paying their way it's not just free
i hate those free handouts you don't
feel like yourself you know to change
their narrative
it's something you know just something
just get involved somehow when i was a
kid
i worked you know at stewart's cleaners
when i was 13 years old i get a check
and
there was a little teeny money dollar 80
whatever taken out of my 30
a month check right for taxes i'll never
forget the first time mom i'm a taxpayer
look bob look they took money out for
taxes
you are the total optimist oh most
people are like i gotta pay i was happy
i paid obama attacked kai vote no but i
paid taxes
i felt good so when they say well no one
pays any tax up to
i don't know whether twenty thirty forty
fifty thousand whatever well can't they
pay it even one percent
because then you feel like you are part
of society
and it's not a handout the more handouts
you get the more you expect
the more you justify your your handout
and the more maybe political parties say
we'll give you more handouts if you know
but vote for us more handouts you'll
have to pay for the issue and pay for
that
so people use that a post realizing we
are very powerful
entities we are the power of one it can
accomplish anything
that we really want to 100 be full of
negative ideas
negativity will come in there be full of
positive ideas and believe in yourself
and positivity comes out of it
um i i 100 percent agree
don't hang around people that are
complaining all the time stay away from
them
right you're right i just i just just
had that conversation on my social media
platform about friends and the key
kind of people that you have around you
and are they the kind of people that you
know
bring you up or do they pull you down do
you feel your energy shift with them are
they
you know basically are they are they
energy vampires are they toxic people
are they helping you progress are they
you know are they
are they gossiping and things like that
or are they talking about
you know potential and dreams and and
surrounding yourself with that
so the question i have then based on
some of these things you've said is do
you think that
do you think that um there's
a a mission to keep people small and
keep them in fear or do you think this
is just
human nature to sort of gravitate
towards that energy because it's egoic
based and
that is um it's easier
it's harder to push yourself it's harder
to stretch yourself
so it's it's a kind of the easy way out
but it's oh it's for sure temporary i
mean
you know the the the soul the the
ego is impatient because knows this time
it's limited but the soul is patient
because it knows it has eternity so
you know why do you think there's
propaganda do you think there's a
an actual mission to keep us in this
lower vibrational state
or do you think it's just simply
happening
through let's call it to be kind various
uh political administrations whether it
was in germany during the 30s and 40s
whether it was in other parts of the
world where they made their people
feel like they're going to be greater
and not lesser but immediately gave them
lesser jobs so you guys are going to
build volkswagens you're going to be
digging these things it's giving them
something
to say things will get better and i am
the answer to it
and many countries have done that we go
all the way past our history
a lot of them did it through conquering
in other words it said fear and if you
look at politics today in our country
and other countries too
it's fear keep people under control fear
fear fear fear fear
so i asked some pretty important people
here on this planet
i said why do you think don't you think
it's about time right now that for
example if there's extraterrestrials
around
which there are they just say make an
appearance saying land here we are
you have enough pictures of us now it's
time uh you know
why don't they just do that well all of
a sudden the world realized
they've been people for thousands of
years flying around in these crafts
they're so brilliant and intelligent
they don't kill each other
they think we are the dumbest primitive
society we still kill one another
over the name of god or something i mean
it's like are you kidding these are pre
and there's a reality show in the name
of god you killed him then he killed you
in the name of god
god does are you crazy god doesn't want
guys we're not going to show up yet
but i think mr halyard says it the best
and anyone could go online and see this
type in canadian minister of defense
and then type in ufo you'll see mr
halyar talk a little bit about it's time
for everybody to know about this because
we can handle it it's not going to
totally destroy our earth
so things may be held down but now
they're all coming out
so you'd said in the past where things
sell possibly and i know with different
countries and leaderships it was
but now it's coming out and there's
nothing they can do about it
people always want to join the masses
okay the masses are going for yay let's
go for the masses right
if it's popular with the masses i'm not
going to be part of it
but what they forget is the masses are
made up of individuals
and it's the power of one that can
change it all
it's the power of one that could change
the masses but if you do what you want
to do not what else someone is telling
you to do you know it's right
you're your own mass of one and if it is
right and it's good
others join you along the way strengthen
one
so are you gonna storm area 51 i don't
know did you sign a petition
what do you have do you have a do you
have a story or a situation that made
you
um either prove to you that
i mean i 100 believe in aliens there's
no way we're the only people out there
i watched a great series i can't wait
for season two to start
it's on fx it's called project blue book
and it was all about
all the sightings that were happening in
the 50s and 60s
and so each episode would dive into
one of those sightings and at the end of
the episode it would give you the it
would show you the
newspaper clippings and the uh the
headlines that were
um you know that talked about that and
it would also of course show you what
show you the pressure to cover it up the
pressure within the government to cover
it up the pressure just for
scientists to cover it up to come up
with some kind of halfway logical reason
why something happened um it also talked
about mind control in there and
and all of those things but um but was
there do you have
do you have a why where did you arrive
how did you arrive here
i have spoken to people
that are some of the most credible
people on the planet
that have seen them okay and touch me
but
under our control there was an in our
space not someone else's
by the way after you go secretary of
defense canada then type in
secretary of defense england the united
kingdom same thing ufo
see what they have to say then yeah you
really think the president has a
like i mean i feel like there's stories
in history about presidents wanting to
know what's going on and they're not
really allowed and they're not privy to
that information
that's true is that um to protect them
from from from the pressure of
being having to answer is this just that
there are people above the president
yeah and there are people both the
president a couple of our presidents
obviously and i think clinton made a big
deal out of it so did carter
they said i won the cia1c we have here
on i believe was the cia
i will see what we have here on ufos
flying sausages nope that's only
uh for up for certain eyes only and
you're not of that
caliber of to go on that special a
little less i believe them to carter too
why do you think that they hide that
from us uh i think it's because uh
guys not the ones that you know right
now you're not going to go along with
whatever the story is
but i can understand it also because all
of a sudden yeah saucers going all over
the place
it'd be like take an aborigine and put
them on an escalator for the first time
obviously the steps are moving he's
totally insane but i would say if
anything
this is my personal thought with all the
movies that are going on right now and
all this leaking out that leaking out
within the decade maybe in the next five
years i think it'll be more exposed
yeah i i think it's a great thing i
think that i think i feel like one of
the presidents
said maybe it was maybe it was ronald
reagan that said
you know if we knew that there was
another entity out there if they we knew
that there was an alien race
how we would come together and realize
how similar we are we would join we
would join up
now the question is is how would we all
react will we join up in a positive
loving way or will we join up in a
fearful way
it's documented by the way that uh
reagan
did experience a flying saucer
experience and so did carter they both
did and they talked about it
they talked about it much but yeah how
would they react well i think it's a
little reverse
is are they ready for us or can we just
silently help this race
to stop killing one another in the name
of god and every other stupid reason you
could ever imagine
right you know we are part children of
god ourselves and we know it's peace and
tranquility makes the world work
not kill that guy because he doesn't
believe the way aren't they normally
found near nuclear sites
where there's where they can disarm
nuclear weapons
they could do that very rapidly yeah
yeah they don't even have to be there i
mean
they they're very very it really starts
to explain the crazy things like when i
was a kid my dad's
i you know we're talking about you know
the pyramids in egypt and he goes aliens
built him that's what he'd always say as
a kid i don't really think much about it
but
i think that kind of probably you know
that seed was for sure planted from
a young age but it would start
explaining whether it be
easter island or the pyramids
or the all the mayan temples throughout
south america
it would start to explain how or
stonehenge and how the
rock formations came and how that they
had anti-gravitation like
anti-levitational gravitation
no anti levity
anti-gravity levitation thank you thank
you tongue twister
but how they were able to use those
technologies to move things
i mean if you look at just simply what
vibration we all
are vibration anyway um
i loved that i love that thought of that
if you collected all the matter of each
human being is the size of an apple i
think that that that concept is amazing
and that we are all just sort of
vibrating energy your
nucleus is vibrating like a little storm
and um and so that kind of energy
can can move
maybe not mountains but maybe oh it it
can move a lot and when people know more
and more about our history
it's like during uh when during the
biblical days okay and some jesuit
priests that told me about this
if there's something in the bible that
doesn't correlate with something science
has already proven just remember that
the bible was written by man not by god
now of course
god influenced them there's no question
on that but still a man occasionally can
make a mistake when they write something
darwin so they say the world is 5 000
years old well obviously it's not
okay but that's a little mistake darwin
comes along and with whatever knowledge
he had at the time
he went through the evolution you know
you start out here and you see that all
of a sudden you're a monkey and you're a
chimpanzee and then
a quote my own uh and the adrenthal and
all of a sudden where are we
well all of a sudden dna came along a
short time ago
where you could dissect anything that's
organic and then they started dissecting
some old mummies and old relics going
all the way back and all of a sudden
discovered
our species you mean okay we're 200 000
years old
we are not an extension of neanderthals
unless some of our people made it with
them back there in those days i don't
know
but uh it was it's a it's an incredible
book that was written by the way i was
just
fascinated with it it's non-religious
it's just all about facts
and it's called uh human by design like
human beings by design
but talks about we humans and the
interesting thing is that the humans
have today you and me
are almost identical other than maybe
had a little more facial hair
that we are today they were 200 000
years ago and that was
somehow they don't give little details
but we were we were
created now did a god in something in
the bible the adam and eve story was
that it but just twist a little bit
don't know
let's just say we let your mind read
fact and you figured out yourself well
then it dives into
incorporating aliens again that that
i've
read and heard things about our dna
being spliced and
looking as if it's been altered it does
exactly
that's what the book talks about okay
yes so that we have
not naturally evolved hundred percent we
have been altered along the way
by intervention of sorts from uh
aliens too that's what it appears to be
it appears to be that way you know and
all of those advanced children quickly
essentially is what they say
well god's little children yeah and you
know what at the end of the day too when
you look at even the
you look at the bible and it says you
know even even
you know god made man if adam and eve
didn't just pop up well it doesn't mean
he didn't make them like it doesn't mean
that they didn't start here to become
here
that's correct when you take linear time
away and you take
time and space away and you just who
knows how long
what's a day in the universe time starts
bending
exactly when you travel at a faster
speed so
like you know it's just a giant loop and
things are happening do you believe in
parallel universes then too
now you know how we get around
wait what do you mean we i'm sorry let's
see how
now we know how in in life we'll be
getting around okay there's a speed of
light and i'll give you an example of
how things are going to be changing very
fast in your life
and your lives too out there everybody
whoever's watching this okay
uh i'm part of the advisory board of the
university of texas
and we're one of the ten groups building
this new telescope up in the mountains
of
chile it'll be up and running by 2024.
it's only four years from now all right
now scientifically we are
meaning the universe is about 15 billion
years
old okay earth they've proven it's
almost
5 billion years old okay now if you shut
the
sun off and you're on earth and you just
shut the sun off you wouldn't know it
for eight minutes
the speed of light okay takes that long
if allison is off and you turn the light
on
you wouldn't know the sun was shining
for eight minutes right okay
they say many of the comments and flying
stars that we see right now
it happened millions of years ago but
right now it's reaching us okay
so this gives you a perspective all
right this telescope will see
within 100 million years
of the start of the universe 100 million
years is nothing in billions of years
and billions
yeah 100 million as they could see so
far with such clarity
and the technology obviously is very
confidential technology right now but
you could see into the if you could see
you could imagine up to a hundred
million years 100 million years
yeah you see the before earth and
everything else
within four years so this gives you an
idea of what's happening now the
technology now that's being shared
so let's say there were crashes or there
were recoveries or was technology that
was found
well it's already felt its way down into
industry you see that in our stealth
fighters the military has a lot of it
but you're also seeing ways how it helps
mankind
and things they use every single day
like yo kevlar for example not just to
stop bullets
but help protect us in case we run into
a rock or something
so many great things the transistors all
these other wonderful things to help
mankind
that all happened really really fast and
i think within the next
maybe even five years we'll have a cure
for cancer i'm i'm pretty sure we will
that'll be
i agree and i don't think it'll be the
conventional way that we all think so
with medicine
i think that we we work as human beings
on a
on a frequency and um i agree i think
that
i think that's for sure coming too
fascinating
um you know you're such a
such a thoughtful person um and
something that struck me
um is just how charitable you are and
um there's a good quote of yours is that
success
unshared is failure can you explain that
sure
uh i think it's because i've been so low
in my life and so down and out and
homeless a couple of times right i know
it's like to have
absolutely nothing and at one time i had
a two and a half year old kid in my
heart right so it's like
it was very very difficult so i know
it's like so when all of a sudden you
have a place to live okay
and you know running water and food in
your bills are you are being paid even
though they're late they're being paid
you know that's kind of success and all
of a sudden one day happens in your life
and uh
my god i could pay my bills on time that
was one of my biggest things was
two years in business with paul mitchell
i could pay my bills on time yay
didn't pay them off and paid them on
time all of a sudden you're successful
oh my god this is great i'm doing my job
i love what i'm doing
well that success isn't shared one way
or another you're a failure
and i have other people that i know that
are extremely wealthy that don't want to
share their money
now you're not giving your money away i
don't give money away i do projects like
mobile loaves and fishes
i donate to i started grow appalachia i
think i help responsibility for the
majority of 4
000 african children babies that die
parents died of aids
ages 1 to you know 12 years old we take
care of them because they have no
parents i mean just all over the world
but because we're successful we have
more i think god
gives that to us so we can take care of
our fellow man and i do
uh there was a lady running for one of
the ladies running for
president united states under the
democrats right now and she and i had an
interesting conversation i said you are
great you believe in the metaphysics
you believe in love and you are
incredible i want to get behind your
bandwagon by the way
what are your feelings on taxes and then
she said well
uh for the wealthy anyone that has over
50 million dollars okay
i agree with elizabeth these other
people your wealth is gonna go down
two percent a year she says two cents on
tv this one lady right this way two
percent
i said if your wealth goes down two
percent a year do you know anything
about the giving pledge
and she didn't have a clue what the
giving pledge was i said there's about
170 of us that are
americans the others that we have are
from all over the world but about 170
are americans we're all billionaires
we've all pledged to give away half our
wealth
while we're alive after we die or a
combination of the two
and most of the star deliberation i
didn't know that i said well
that means that at two percent a year
within 30 years
half my fortune's gone half my giving's
gone everybody else
and i worked for it and i do a better
job and so i figured that she'd say oh
well we'll make some kind of allowance
she liked me nine said
when i'm elected you'll have two years
that i'm coming after you guys
i said do you remember i just said i was
blown away and she was i think she's a
wonderful lady a nice lady but
somehow she got that in her thought but
she didn't think it out
she didn't think it out it's like when i
went on tv
this is the last year of the obama
administration when it was a lot of one
percent versus 99 percent and by the way
i am an independent i'm not a republican
i'm not a democrat i'm an independent
okay and
i believe in the environment people
aren't most people kind of in the middle
i think so many
tell me your story so i can figure out
if i like you so they bring me on tv
right and i'm going to rep this is
worldwide tv so i'm representing the one
percent
i said this will be fun so i said well
jp what's it like being the one percent
because you come from being poor you
know having nothing
and you help a lot without what's like
being one the one representing the one
percent on our show
and i said oh no i'm not only the one
percent i'm the 99 percent too
and of course the show kind of stopped i
said are you kidding
i go to work every day i share with
everybody
i mean it's like it's we the people of
the united states of america there's
this big thing down there
i think the smithsonian that says we the
people of the united states of america
in order to
isn't it we the people so why do people
want to take the one percent divide the
99
isn't it the american dream to have a
house own a car and maybe one day be a
millionaire and
no disrespect to heavy-duty socialist no
disrespect we all have our own way of
doing things right
but guys don't take the american dream
away the american dream is to have that
chance to make it
and if you make it look at some of us in
the giving pledge we give
and give but we invest it to make you
better
we don't say here's your fish we show
you how to fish we'll dig the water well
then show you how to farm
we'll build your house to live in but
then show you how to create something
around it yeah grapple asia
i'll buy everything you need here when
there's unemployment in the united
states in 19 in 2010
your your your siege your fertilizer
know-how here's knowledge how to do it
everything you need is provide here's a
tractor you want 50 farms together it's
yours
first year you learn how to feed
yourself and your family and can for the
winter
now you got food year out second year
you grow a little more
and you sell it at local stores as
organically owned produce at a farmers
market now you have an income
and by the way here's 12 chickens you've
got eggs
here's some bees all of a sudden people
now have their own way of doing
something and become self-sufficient
most of us look at programs like that
and people are into
are individuals right so you say we're
all one but we're all individual too so
you're gonna
have your own unique expression of
what's important to you what resonates
with you and how you want to give back
and how you want to share it
and that's not going to be all the same
right which is going to spread it even
better
because while you invest into you know
the
the less fortunate and animals and the
environment somebody else might be all
for
cancer and you know of you know female
you know women's women's rights somebody
might be for
um you know whatever it is that that
strikes them and like hits their heart
but
you know to try and then say that we're
going to take your money and
and do whatever we want with it i feel
like it's very one-sided for the
expression
to the expression correct i think it's
going to happen when people have ideas
like
that and people start believing
everything they're on television and
they think oh this is free
it's not the right attitude it's the
attitude of well
the oyster and the eagle may i tell you
the story it's very short it takes three
minutes ago
when god created this planet he created
an oyster and said oyster i'm going to
put you in the shell
and at the bottom of the ocean i'm
protecting you from your enemies i'm
giving you free rent
you want food open your mouth food will
rush in
food clothing shelter and care total
soil should be totally taken care of
but you're not going to go anywhere then
god created an eagle it's an eagle
whole different species go build your
own house on top of a mountain or a tree
or someplace like that
you want to eat go fly around and find
your food and eagles fly through
sometimes miles of winds you know sleet
snow hail whatever
to feed themselves the eagle fails
95 of the time it's so big and
cumbersome so when it comes down on its
prey
it's usually while prey gets away but it
keeps on going going going until it
finally gets it
now that eagle is the strongest bird in
the sky
it never gave up it didn't have anything
for free did it on its own
but that eagle can go anywhere it wants
the eagle and not the oyster is the
emblem of america
we just have to think a little more like
eagles opposed to oysters and get their
participate and grow and no matter how
bad things on your life no matter how
times you've been fired how many times
you've lost this how homeless you are
there's a way out for you if you believe
in yourself and
the other secret is even if you have no
money help others along the way
how do i help them out of have no money
well how about volunteering at christmas
at thanksgiving
go to the union rescue mission you know
go to the go to all these places go to
griffith park and help feed the homeless
who taught you that i just my mom
actually my mom and may i give her just
a second credit to my mama
we had nothing lived in downtown l.a
deadbeat dad
were you were you a poor family growing
up too yeah we had a deadbeat dad so
from
less than i was two years old my mom
raises very very difficult for us but
at six years old she took us to downtown
l.a it was different than today
we had the bullocks the broadway all
these really cool department stores main
company with
all these christmas things going on in
front of them you ride the little train
you see the
with the luckiest kids in the world we
took the streetcar down
used to be a little streetcars anyways
it was oh it's wonderful
we thought we were the luckiest kids in
the world so my mom that year
this would be 1950 gave my brother and i
51 a dime and said boys
each of you with little fingers you know
hold this dime in half go over and give
that man ring the
the belt the bucket we did we put in
that red bucket and
we said mom why why do we give that man
the red bucket there
a dime in those days that's two large
soda pops and three candy bars
oh god mom and she said boys that's the
salvation army
and they help feed people and give
people places to live
that have nothing says boys always
remember in your lives
that they'll always be people that have
less than you are we can only afford a
dime this year
but we're giving something and if and i
would i try to volunteer a little bit
for the red cross to help raise money
for them
but i couldn't do that a lot cause i got
to take care of you kids but now you
kids are participating with me with this
time
and i never forgot it so even in my
riding with the hells angels and satan
slave days many many years ago you were
in the hell's angels i rode with them
they were okay
similar though well you'll you'll you'll
see when you see good folks okay okay
okay anyways but at uh whenever we used
to have lovens in griffith park and i
lived here in l.a
and i would go there at thanksgiving or
christmas and even with my little son
when i inherited him also
and helped serve food i just felt good
to do
it just felt good to do it's kind of
once you start doing things like that
and some bread helps somebody else out
it's um it's like getting gifts for
people you know it's really like once
you start doing it you realize how
much better you feel doing how much more
fun it is instead of like
one more damn t-shirt down the street
you know another another another jacket
another pair of jeans it's like
to share and to um see somebody light up
because of what you're doing is so much
more powerful
the biggest thing anyone can do today
you want to do something different an
anc reaction
get on an elevator or an escalator turn
right around and look at the people on
there and smile
good morning or good afternoon hi guys
that's all i just turn around again and
you'll be amazed all of a sudden
there'll be few of any people that won't
smile back and well thank you are you
having a good day too
it just opens up relationships happy
you've been described as being
unstoppably
positive and um i just i mean i can feel
that i can see that
and you've told me how you know you grew
up in a family that
you had you know not a lot of money and
you had a deadbeat dad and
your mom was obviously a really positive
influence so
how do you get to the point how do you
get to where you're at
how do you think the way you think how
can you
self-actualize how can you be positive
do you have can you identify a reason
well for me it's a little easier than
maybe for some people because one
when you're down and out more than once
you don't know money no nothing
and something good happens oh boy this
is great but i was with all due respect
i was born i think positive i i my mom
would always tell me my god
be careful mom i'm gonna be just fine i
was kind of think more and positive
you know then obviously when you're down
you go up you get even more positive
because you're so happy
and then when you have an abundance of
something and you get to share it with
people and you see a good end result
it's just
it's happy if you ever you do something
for somebody else
and ask absolutely nothing in return
it's the greatest high you'll ever get
now i went through the 60s okay
it's the greatest high you'll ever get
when you help somebody say that
and you ask nothing in return yes
absolutely nothing in return
it's higher than smoking anything is
that what you how you would describe a
good giver
yeah when you give to somebody or
something or some environment whether
it's the environment for the planet or
for people
and you ask nothing in return you do it
because it's the thing to do
oh you get a good high everyone likes
being knowledge but do it sometime and
don't tell anybody you did it like
there'll be times
austin especially i'll go downtown and
when i'm in l.a i'll do it because i was
homeless here once
and i'll hand out hundred dollar bills
i'll just go back to this for you
and i just keep on walking and one lady
i gave a stack to it was a ten thousand
dollar stack
she was just the kind of sweetest lady
and i talked to her a little bit
she told me a little about her life and
i said can i give you a couple dollars
oh no no
i found out a way to make it okay
because i don't like to ask for anything
they said okay so i just held her hand
and i said can i put a note in your
pocket sure so i just put
a note in the pocket i realized just
built ten thousand output in her pocket
there was folded
with a rubber band i said you are so
blessed
once you wait a few minutes before
reading my note say a little prayer then
read that out okay
and i disappeared did you hear her
scream
nope they just disappeared was he
listening
you are a um you are a very positive
person
and you know i can i can i can associate
with some of that you know i can
associate with the business positive
like i get the way that you get about
something where i believe it's gonna
work and i just like
kind of blinders almost to like however
someone thinks i should do it but
i don't think i have that in all of my
life like you seem to do you have that
in your personal life too
i just assume i do
i just assume i do one day
you'll be interviewing like we're
interviewing right now and you'll hear
every word i say this will be in your
lifetime you'll hear every word i say
and i won't even open my mouth and
you'll hear every single word and i'll
hear everything that you're saying or
thinking and you would open your mouth
once again it's because the frequency of
everything is right is
is growing now it's driving it's like
the energy we have today
is already extending out of our body
because if for me to go over there and
touch your hand for example right now
okay
i'd have to touch it for you to feel it
right okay
right
okay and then what two inches of rubber
an inch above you
okay it's free a fellow named pedro
reyes
jr told me about that he was famous i
think for being in the philippines top
rate on people with his hand
go right into the operation come right
out there's nothing left
but i met with him once in hong kong and
he had told me that we humans if only we
knew
these bodies that we're in right now
that we have these abilities and we have
the intention
of carrying them forward all of a sudden
they will start happening
it's just how we believe and whatever
that mind can believe
and truly believe and conceive it'll
achieve
very strong i mean the bible said that
didn't it it said
i think jesus said anything that i can
do you can do even more
yeah you just have to remember you are
gods
why do people have such a hard time with
that why do people
why do we think we're smaller than that
why do we not think that we're on the
same level
i think it's because most people and
this is no disrespect to any religion or
any
way of thinking or philosophy idolized
like
there is one god and there's a whole
bunch of us down here
unrealizing that every one of us is part
of that one god
god sees and acts through us he sees you
he tastes things through you and because
he's so
unreal look what the man created he
could do this
billions of times through billions of
people it's like when i first started
dialing phone numbers
mutual 8341 my original phone number
okay i was a little kid
all of a sudden now we had six stages
then we had seven digits now we have 10
digits
all of a sudden the mind is pulling
those in when it was hard to go from
four digits to five digits or five to
six
yeah so you know once again things are
improving because
one another as we all progress and we
all lift our frequency
we lift others along the way with us and
it makes for a better world so
there's a lot of good stuff in the
future up and coming here i can tell you
that
how did you come to um believe in
frequency
uh i just know
so back to reincarnation now i knew we'd
get back here
how do is this do uh past lives do you
believe in
the you know the the collective
consciousness
akashic records um just about everything
you said like i could see more auras now
that
i didn't see before i could uh be in the
color's mine
right now it's kind of goldish white
yeah remember that came from it's kind
of cold it's white
nice nice uh but uh and also able to and
this just happened the last year for
whatever reason when i was in
switzerland
i saw this beautiful mountainside full
of grass and it was like neon green
and i didn't take anything since i drank
too much or didn't took anything right
it was really neon green
and then i started looking as we were
driving in old classical cars around
switzerland neon green
when i got back to the united states the
lawns were more neon green me the green
was so
green it was almost like a neon green
and it just all of a sudden happened so
that's going to be your favorite
perception wise
yeah perception perception of it
happened it was like you know
something more intense so instead of
seeing black and white we start to see
color
is this in the 60s this is all right now
oh right now i was going to say
it was the mushrooms no it wasn't the
mushrooms they weren't eating mushrooms
that day
maybe the carrot you know but no but all
of a sudden and so these are things that
are indications
i'll be going and all of a sudden
something calls my attention over here
and i turn and thank god i saw that
because that's the person i was looking
for
or that's what i wanted and that's a
frequency because we're all electric
so that frequency as it goes up it gets
stronger a very good friend of mine
is hell put off they made a movie about
hal with uh
george clooney called i think talking to
goats about remote viewing
he headed up he headed up the remote
viewing for our agency
oh wow it's real where you could be deep
in the united states and see what's
going on in russia well they have remote
viewers too
and so people are able to secret well
that's a frequency
that if you're able to do something like
that and people can be taught to do that
that's a frequency i've heard that the
government recruits people that have the
ability to do remote viewing
and brings them in-house so that they
can understand more of what's going on
or partially and then teaches them how
to do it which if people don't know
remote viewing is the ability to
obviously be able to see what's going on
um when you're not there exactly it's
time
for the energy time and space is no
longer and
part of it it's just the energy and i
just have a feeling that maybe all
countries are doing that still you know
i'm sure they are i mean they've been
again back to
project blue book i mean part of it is
about mind control and when i've
all the things that i've read and
watched is that back in the 50s they
were really pushing hard
on figuring out how to control minds
[Music]
and uh sensory deprivation experiments
and um and how they can essentially
reprogram your mind
it's like acid didn't work out very well
for them because people became free
thinkers yeah
i thought that was maybe where lsd came
along that's awesome
that's right i think lsd was to research
uh harvard and the military so that's a
story i had heard
and they thought well we use this
against the enemy or whatever all of a
sudden people are taking say
we want to be free yeah i thought it was
a truth serum they were trying to
develop a truth serum
that's probably better that it was way
more awesome well maybe it was i mean
if you can you know i don't know what
you think of psychedelics but you know
you know removing the veil of you know
perception
and opening up to reality um you know
seems to be what those drugs do if we
could do that more
without even needing the drugs for
example if you were to read that one
book i mentioned to you okay
you know and read it also while you're
reading it something is
written or an idea or a mind flashes in
your mind all of a sudden it's a key
then all of a sudden
oh and it opened up something else it's
like sometimes you could be around
people
that are very very there and when you
walk away
what was that what is energy still with
me then all of a sudden you see things a
little differently
it's all growing in a good way it's
growing you see things so you can read
something that all of a sudden
opens the key to your mind or be around
an energy that opens up the key to your
mind all of a sudden the next day the
next week the next hour or something
you're feeling more like lighter or
better or more understanding or
you know i couldn't hear that before
they're by the front door there but i
could hear them now for some reason
so as many little keys as we're reading
and how we're becoming
educated that opened up i think locked
doors that's my belief
locked doors you know so really credible
people say
some long doors of yours well there's a
lot of doors there okay
if a lot of people here tell you that
you know that's out there and here's the
proof that it's out there
you're exposed to it until finally you
see the proof with your own eyes there's
a
place out in joshua tree that's out here
in the desert uh called the integra
oh i've been there i've done it well let
me tell you the story behind it please
we do
want to tell them for those who don't
know what integrotron is describe
integrtron and then tell your story
because it's a very unique cool thing
is the middle of joshua tree it's a
giant half dome
probably 75 feet across like a big half
down it's got an armature meaning
something go around the outside with
some things sticking in
if you go on the inside you can hear a
little bit of an echo
people are there right now they make
crystal therapy they put crystals in
there
that's what i'm told anyways
oh yeah tell me the beginning and then
i'll tell i'll tell you what it is now
crystals are in there right they get i
went there two years ago
this great energy feeling well many many
years ago like about almost 50 years ago
i was out there visiting a friend and i
was much younger than i am right now
and they told me about this guy named dr
george von tossel and his wife doris who
built something called an integratron
in the middle of the desert and there's
a lot of flying saucers
out there or viewings of flying saucer
she says believe me you're meant to go
there
so as we're going there let's say there
may have been something that zoomed by
let's just say there may have been i
don't know who knows okay anyways i go
out there
and i meet with them i walk into this
room and there was about a
maybe a half dozen eight people there
they looked like they were 500 years old
i mean these are elderly people right
george fontes i guess him somewhere in
his 60s 70s 80s hard to tell
anyways he said oh welcome we've been
expecting you
joan did you say something no he said
anyways
we are the college of universal wisdom
and let's take you for a walk they took
me in the backyard there's this giant
monolithic
bolder out there right and there was a
house underneath they took me into the
house underneath and showed me some of
the equipment there and somebody was
living there
they said we have a lot of people coming
over because there's a lot of you know
ufos that land here oh by the way would
you like to see what one looks like
sure and then they show me pictures look
at his backyards
anyways let me continue with the story
so they take me inside the integration
they say
we need young people we'd like you to be
on our board of directors
and i said but i know very little about
this stuff they said you'll know believe
me
trust us and the next year you'll know a
lot more okay cool so he takes me inside
this integration which you've been he
says
this came from them many
extraterrestrials or people
are not the kinds that we know and i'm
building it for their instructions and
what i'm going to do is i'm creating
inside a negative ion but a special type
of negative ion
so the outside is actually an electric
motor when it's done it's going to spin
this way create inside a negative ion
and as people walk through with cancer
that cancer is going to be
gone it's going to boost up their immune
system so much
it's going to cure cancer by the time
the government murdered everyone
anyway so this is a very strange story
i'm not saying anybody who murdered who
but oh gosh about 40
gosh it must have been 70
yeah right around 1976. i got a call
on my home phone we'd have cell phones
in those days from doris fontaso
she was a doctor slash chiropractor says
jp i have some news for you
but believe me everything's okay george
died last night
okay i want you to come out here i said
well oh gosh he still he says well jp
have already had his body cremated
she could sign this certificate and
create his body
so of course i went out there and we
said she says george has left us
and his wish was to be cremated so we
it's been cremated
already so before the sun came up you
know all of a sudden george's cree made
it right it's not there anymore
and she says uh we're going through some
changes right now
uh we're gonna try and hang on this
integratron
but there's a lot of forces that don't
think what we're doing is right think
it's a hoax and
there's others that know it's for real
but don't want us to finish
uh just want to let you know that i
don't know where the college is going
from here on out
but the other people i guess was the
other members or something said stay
away for a while
you know and that was the last time i
was out there but that was developed as
an outside armature that spins around
creating negative ion force inside
the actual building spin or was it
something inside
do they still have a ring around the
outside yeah whatever okay
well that was to have armatures that
would stick out this far
cut put it safe screwed in there and
then would rotate be like a motor
turned inside out and would rotate
around to create
and with there was another mechanism
that was to the
north part of the building towards on
top there that was let me call it the
whatever made the the contact create
that heavy negative
ion force was sitting up there so as it
spun around
that actually helped give off that
negative ion force
what do you think interesting so what's
happening after now what's happening
after now
well integra toronto is very busy i mean
it's like
you have a hard time getting an
appointment and
so they do sound healing now and there
and so you
like you said it's the dome but it's
it's like a
it's a raised dome there's almost like a
silo to it
and so because when you go in the bottom
it's kind of the holding area
and then you walk up some some some
curly stairs
up into the platform where you lay down
and get comfortable on your little mat
that'd be the top of the dome
that's on the dome so it's inside the
dome but it says this but there's two
there's a level inside the dome
that was there was empty there was no
level okay yep they've built a platform
now
that's completely covered and so they
the stairs go up
you shut the hatch you're in that area
they have
um all the crystal bowls for
um all your chakras so they start at the
root chakra and work their way up to the
crown chakra
and play the crystal bowls and so the
session is about 25 minutes long
um and that's it that's your experience
at integratron
but i have bought a t-shirt and my
t-shirt says has like planets on it and
it has a flying saucer in the middle
and it says integratron and i love it oh
great excellent very good how did you
feel when you got out
oh i mean i felt rested yeah i just felt
peaceful
cool yeah it was you should maybe go
back
i will i always want to go out there and
talk to them and ask them do you know
what you have or what its primary
purpose
was i don't i could even show them where
the lines were run
because i'm sure someone pulled those
out and buried them but i could uh
i could even show them where the lines
were run wow
let's make a date let's go out there
i've been wanting to do that for years
just haven't gotten around to it maybe
this is the extra motivation
um i know i've been keeping you a long
time this is very interesting though
um what is your
what's your definition of success
success
is not how much money you have which i
said before success is
how you good good how well how good do
you do what you do
when nobody's looking how far have you
come
at what you do how far have you come
example
i was the biggest success as a janitor
you could ever imagine at stewart's
cleaners
by this time i'm 16 years old stuart
calls me in one day i
put the little blankets on the hangers
the little sleeve and i brush the
blankets and i clean the place right
calls me in one day and says johnny i
want to talk to you
i think oh no stewart the biggest
tightwad in the world is paying me a
dollar and a quarter now or he's not
going to pay me anymore he's going to
fire me
he says i was on the mezzanine last
night i was working late
so i want to lay down on my cot my watch
out fell on the floor went down again
and looked under the cot
and there was no dust so the bed the old
cots are metal
just pulled it back looked he says
there's no dust i look behind
the file kit no dust he says you move
everything i said well yes sir i said my
mom taught me how to clean and i was
like kid and
i like my job and i'm your janitor and
that's my job to do you know
he said i've never seen anybody work
like that before i'm so happy i'm gonna
give you a raise to a dollar fifty an
hour
now where i went to high school i was
probably the highest paid kid in school
for bucking a dollar fifty an hour it
was like
wow it's only about ten cents did so oh
yeah well this is lily and i'm 16.
i'm not six anymore you know that's a
lot of money and i think he paid the one
and a quarter because that was a lot at
the time
if you're a kid you had to make a buck
in a quarter hour so i thought
man i'm one of the most successful
janitors on the planet perception
yeah it's not what you're doing is how
far have you gone how well do you do
what you do
especially when no one else is looking
that's success
what are some what are some things that
we can do as regular mortals um to
arrive at a space where we feel this
undeniable positivity where we
give without any expectation of
receiving where we
dream and we believe in those dreams and
we know how
and we can be connected to the self is
there a certain um
a few things that maybe we can do in our
our regular waking lives
like journal or you know meditate or
whatever i mean you've told me your
morning routine but are there some
things that we can do that would help
that
one thing that really helps and you
brought it up while you're interviewing
me with an example
there's a lot of people it's human
nature they just want to complain and
gossip and just talk about the
negativity about everything right yeah
stay away from those people as agape
says a great writer agape a friend of
mine she says
you can still love them but from afar
you know you go over there
you know you stay overnight i still
loving the state of my life
you know just keep some distance try and
surround yourself with people
that are positive thinking very very
important it's like enthusiasm
enthusiasm is contagious
right well negativity is too stay away
from those people now in your own life
we all have problems
and i did this years ago my first couple
years with paul mitchell i would
go to bed at night and i can't sleep so
i'm wearing i can't pay the bills
did that help any no okay but you can't
sleep
so i just started writing stuff down so
i couldn't sleep so i would write down a
piece of paper
the things i was worried about the bills
they campaigned and just what really
bugged me that kept me awake
and then i just took it got a piece of
tape and taped it to my bathroom window
because that's a mirror so when i get up
in the morning it's the first thing i
would see and i would read all the
things and then realize
oh i can go to sleep at night
i haven't lost it it'll be there in the
morning
so i'm not going to forget anything it's
there in the morning and then by the
time
when the side of your mind you get there
that wasn't that important cross cross
and then right next to i'd have an
affirmation like uh you know when the
going's tough the tough get going
some kind of affirmation you know all is
good but we can make it better
there is some kind of positive
affirmation and that i found that to be
just an extra nice thing to look at or
think about and for people that worry
and i would i was in that spot you know
it doesn't help any it's not going to
cure a thing
but if you write it down yeah then you
know okay i don't have to think about
anymore because sorry written down's
gonna be on the american c in the
morning well you're talking about energy
you pull the energy of that
fear or that concern put it on the paper
it's out of you that is correct
so correct and then after a while you
just ripped it over threw it away and
after anymore
burn it ceremonially burn it like under
the full moon
send it off i said blah be free
if we could all just be a little bit
more like you and
we all can i mean that's the thing is
that it's all within us and
i appreciate you sharing your you know
your habits because
um and your thought processes because
it's inspirational so thank you
thank you we have 16 000 students now in
our paul mitchell schools
we have way over 100 paul mitchell
schools part of the curriculum besides
being the greatest place to learn how to
do hair and be a professional stylist
my friend my friend's husband is a hair
stylist and
his uh one of his products that he makes
is in some of your schools
oh fabulous well part of our culture
is in training we take a few months
everyone participates in the culture
giving loving giving back how to treat
everybody
like one another i'll take care of the
little guy it's all in the culture of
our schools
when you see good fortune in the movie
you'll see one aspect where i brought 3
000 students together a couple thousand
students together
and their reaction about caring about
everybody the little guy really really
counts
it's when you're around people like this
or environment this it just continues
and
you've got the same attitude and i hope
everybody that you interview
you have the same kind of message that
you give across from yourself let alone
whatever they could participate in
the world should see your interviews
because you're a good interviewer and
you ask those
good questions thank you well it's is i
would imagine that uh
this is also something that took me that
was impressive
is that you've only had a hundred people
turn over
in your company since 1980 and about
maybe 39 years
i mean that we could be 103 it's you
know but it's close to 100.
maybe since you're still sitting here
i'll keep you for another second and ask
you
because there's a lot of people out
there that have their own businesses
they're some are big some are small
but you've obviously created many very
successful ones
one of which rocket the new smartphone
um which
you showed me has some amazing
technology by the way rocket phones
rocket nassau that's uh that's very cool
but what how what creates what you
talked about the culture
and so you know this is probably pretty
applicable for your life
as much as it is for your business but
you know how have you
what have been what's been the magic
formula and what have would have been
the
the missions and the the the culture
that you've created to keep the people
that long
when i worked for others there were
times where i didn't have a dollar for
lunch
so i made up my mind i'm going to be the
guy
that one day may be lucky enough to have
a business if i am i'm going to take
care of people who i want to be take i
want
that i want myself to be taken care of
so what happened was
as we could afford it which was maybe
three years in business i remembered
lunch everybody gets free lunch from
this day forward you all have free lunch
you still get free lunch if you work at
john paul mitchell systems so we have
free lunch for everybody
and then i realized it's hard for people
to save so when we could afford it
which was maybe 25 years ago maybe even
30 years ago
when we could afford it we all of a
sudden put together a profit sharing
program
where we will take for example let's say
you make so much money we'll take
another 10
not away from you right we'll add it
there and put a retirement program for
you that builds tax-free
and then later on you could also have a
401k if you want that it will make a
little contribution there
and medical insurance god people should
have medical insurance so we gave them
the best plan there is
so when it comes to extra prince
benefits they get it all they also knew
that at any time
you could pick up the phone and call me
now i'm not in california for the last
20 years i'm in texas or flying all over
the world
but i am here about every three or four
weeks for a few days but they know they
get a phone number
and get a hold of me whenever they want
to talk to me one on one and many of
them do that
they also know that we don't put up with
mean people
we had a vice president i found it was
very very mean to our people and i
thought he was a great guy and i liked
him a lot
but when i started finding out how mean
he was to our people and they gave me
some jp we'd like to fire the guy
and here's all the reasons it was you
know as far as i'm concerned for him
just being a mean person a person
he shouldn't be here he should be fired
you can't be mean to people and disgrace
people you know and the other reasons
you gave me two great ideas fire this
guy
um there's take care of your people
where you want to be taken care of
people are treating your people bad
talk to them if they change great if
they don't change
they have to move on well i i believe
that the way that
you take care of yourself is the way
you're willing to take care of others or
even capable of taking care of others
if you don't know how to do that then
you're starting you sort of
look in the mirror start looking in the
mirror i grew up in a good book too for
people to read
about getting in love with people it's
all positive the book is i think
80 years old maybe 90 is called
how to win france and influence people
by del carnegie yeah one of the best
books dale carnegie
yeah i took a dale carnegie speaking
course when i was a kid i was like 14
and one of my sponsors paid for it
and i brought the average age of that
room down at 14 years old by a lot well
of course you did um
but i took a speaking course when i was
14. it was called the dale carnegie
speaking course
but he scrubbed his book you know and i
tell people that all the time how to
talk nice to people
how to win friends by saying the right
things not saying the wrong things to
people
yeah you know good message sure well i
can't wait to uh take our trip to
integratron
i i is it true you've never been drunk
off patron
that's very true i've been high off of
it i've been high up a trauma but never
dropped wait what's the difference
well drugs like you know hai is like hi
guys how you doing
let's dance big difference perception
perception yeah perception good i never
drink enough where i wasn't in control
and if i drank one too many i wouldn't
dry somebody else would do that's very
smart
well i'll i'll bring some of my wine
maybe you like wine cool yeah i do like
wine okay
give your own winery i do wow well
you'll have to tell me about that next
but it's been a pleasure being on your
show thank you you're wonderful
thank you thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today i
hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click
on the subscribe button